i wish to come back on the events that
have been unfolding these last two weeks
in ottawa
first off
i like my colleagues wholeheartedly
condemn the kind of hideous acts and
symbols that we've seen on this play by
some demonstrators
nazi flags and confederate flags have no
place in canada they are symbols of hate
and intolerance and we must always
reject these symbols passionately
and i want to thank all of those who've
denounced these acts these symbols and
these individuals clearly and loudly
i also wish to denounce the far-right
groups that we have seen in these
protests
i've myself received over the years my
fair share of threats from far-right
extremists and i have absolutely
absolutely no sympathy
for them
i profoundly despise what they stand for
with regards to the occupation of
ottawa's downtown core it's time it
stops
it's time for truckers to leave and let
the local population get their
neighborhood back and get their quality
of life back
free of fear and free of harassment
no one wants this to escalate and
protesters should now show some good
will
like we've seen this saturday in my
hometown of quebec city
i suggest they relocate somewhere else
somewhere appropriate for the residents
and for the city of ottawa they could
organize shuttles should they wish to
come demonstrate peacefully before
parliament hill such is their right
but downtown residents also have the
right to piece and order and it has
lasted long enough already
that being said
when it comes to the broader
demonstration
demonstrations we've seen in ottawa in
quebec city and all across the country
i will abstain from the kind of
generalizations that we've heard these
last few days
i've seen on radio canada an interview
with what seemed to be a very kind grand
grandmother who demonstrated for her
grandkids she looked and sounded nothing
like a white supremacist
nor did the black seek and indigenous
canadians i saw demonstrating on my way
to parliament these last two weeks or in
quebec city this last saturday
i have enough respect for my fellow
canadians
not to engage in these easy and absurd
labels
now looking beyond the demonstrations
i've heard from hundreds of constituents
and citizens who took the time to reach
out to me these past weeks
folks who have nothing to do with these
demonstrations who are for the most part
vaccinated who have done everything as
they should these last two years
people people
who have shared with me legitimate
concerns
about where we are heading collectively
i think we must hear these concerns
and i think we must respond to them
i've heard from parents worried to see
their kids sink into depression and
slowly lose their joy of living
i've heard from pediatricians
in tears telling me about their young
patients despair anxiety isolation as
well as the stunning increase in school
dropouts they are observing
i've heard from artists who are on the
brink of mental and financial collapse
after two years with barely enough work
to get by
i've heard from social workers answering
suicide hotlines who are overwhelmed by
the number of calls they're receiving
i've heard from entrepreneurs and
restaurant owners who are contemplating
losing what they've spent their whole
lives building
and that's when it hasn't happened
already
i've heard from fellow quebecers who are
rightfully appalled that in our province
in 2022 we're locking up triple vaxxed
seniors for days on end
i've heard from fellow quebecers
appalled
that in quebec
in january 2022
we have locked up kids aged 6 to 10
years old
for up to 10 days in windowless rooms
kids who tested negative who had no
symptoms who had been in contact with
someone though who had the virus
so let me repeat in quebec in 2022 we
locked up kids aged 6 to 10 for up to 10
days in windowless rooms
let that sink in
this was a public health measure that
had been drafted approved and applied
i've heard from people worried that we
seem collectively to have forgotten that
a population's health is kind of like a
pie and omicron is but a slice of that
pie
economic health
social health and mental health
must be accounted for
i've heard from people worried that
those making the decisions
seem at times to have been blind to the
fact that we're not all equal before
lockdowns
that not everyone can earn a living on a
macbook at the cottage
i've heard people worried that a few
might have lost sight of the quiet and
discreet suffering of the many
i've heard people in great pain to see
some of their friends whom they love
and respect but who've decided for
whatever reason we might very well
disagree with who've decided not to get
vaccinated and as a consequence
are jobless
selling what they have and moving to the
united states away from their
communities away from their friends and
from their families
i've heard from teachers worried to see
kids reenacting in the schoolyard the
kind of discrimination and segregation
we see in our society between vaccinated
and unvaccinated
i've heard from people worried to see
those they care about
fighting each other on this issue
tearing some families and some friends
apart
i've heard from a lot of people
wondering why just a year ago we were
all united
all in this together
and now that we have one of the most
vaccinated population in the world
we've never been so divided
now these people are increasingly
confused
when on the other hand they hear experts
like dr carl weiss a renowned quebec
epidemiologist
state last week and i quote
that covet 19 is here to stay
that those at risk will have to be
monitored closely when symptoms appear
that we will have to protect our health
care systems but that we will also have
to live with the virus like we do with
influenza
that we can go back to lockdowns and
restrictions not supported by science
they're confused when they hear dr tam
state last week that all existing public
health policies including vaccine
passports need to be re-examined and
that we need to have
longer-term sustained approaches and
capacity building so we're not in crisis
mode all the time as we fight this virus
they're confused when they see the
undeniable trend around the world
whereby for instance the world health
organization recently recommended
dropping or alleviating many border
measures including vaccine requirements
as they've proven to be ineffective in
fighting the propagation of the omicron
variant
that's the world health organization
they're confused when they see countries
around the world like ireland sweden
norway
switzerland the czech republic israel
denmark spain and the uk who have either
dropped almost all restrictions or are
fast moving in that direction
all countries i note with lower
vaccination rates than us
now while folks are hearing and seeing
all of this they're left rightfully
wondering
where the hell are we heading here in
canada
i think there lies the frustration
they feel there is no appetite from our
government to adapt so as to reflect the
changing data
and the changing reality of the pandemic
and of the world
they're worried that measures which
ought to be exceptional and limited in
time are being normalized with no end in
sight like vaccine passports mandates
and requirements for travelers
they're worried because they feel they
feel it is becoming harder and harder to
know where public health stops
and where politics begins
now i firmly believe governments would
do well not to dismiss these legitimate
concerns
and not to demonize those who voice them
to the contrary i believe these concerns
need to be addressed head on
and here are some ways i humbly submit
we could go about it
first
i believe the government should provide
quickly a roadmap with clear and
measurable targets to lift all
restrictions within its purview
to be clear i do not necessarily believe
that all measures should be lifted
immediately but i do believe that we
must have a clear and measurable
benchmark for when measures will be
lifted
for instance
at what point can we lift restrictions
while respecting the capacity of the
province's health care systems
second
i believe that if more and more
canadians find it hard to comply with
the restrictions
it's not because they lack solidarity
it's because increasingly canadians
don't understand the measures and they
don't understand them because
governments no longer care to explain
them
it's a lot easier to comply when you
understand particularly when these
restrictions impact your day-to-day life
the vaccine requirement for truckers to
me is a good example and if we forget
about the demonstrations and we forget
about the convoy for just a second and
look at that policy for what it is
this is a policy that now goes against
the world health organization's
recommendation
and for which no epidemiological
studies and projections have been
provided
meanwhile the industry is clear
when this measure took effect the price
of transport for fresh products from the
united states went up by 15 to 20
percent on average
now i understand there are many factors
contributing to inflation but inflation
happens over time not overnight
this is not a small consequence given
that canadians are already facing the
highest inflation in 30 years
and unfortunately it affects more the
most vulnerable amongst us the impact is
not the same if you make 200 or 300 000
a year versus if you make 15 to 20 bucks
an hour
at least if the benefits were clearly
explained with data and projections not
with talking points it could make the
burden more bearable
i've been looking for this data for
weeks but to no avail
this leads me to humbly suggest that the
government should systematically publish
the epidemiological projections and the
scientific analysis underpinning the
measures it imposes going forward
third
to echo the comments i quoted earlier by
dr tam
we need to be building our capacity
right now to face the next waves
as such i believe the government should
start negotiating the canada health
transfers with provinces without delays
the government's position is quite
frankly
hard to understand
on the one hand
we say that we will not be negotiating
the transfer before the pandemic ends
and on the other hand we say that the
pandemic will last for years
if we want to be able to truly live with
the virus without resorting to the
violence of lockdowns these discussions
cannot wait
there's no doubt that provinces have a
lot to do to improve their health care
systems and to gain inefficiency
but the federal government
also has its role to play
at last
i think it's time to stop dividing
canadians to stop pitting one part of
the population against another i can't
help but notice with regret that both
the tone and the policies of my
government
changed drastically on the eve and
during the last election campaign
from a positive and unifying approach a
decision was made to wedge to divide and
to stigmatize
i fear that this politicization
of the pandemic risks undermining the
public's trust in our public health
institutions
this is not a risk we ought to be taking
lightly
in this last year canada has reached one
of the highest levels of vaccination in
the world it is something we should be
proud of it is something we should be
celebrating
yet here we are
more divided than ever
it's time to stop with the division and
the distractions
it's time to choose positive not
coercive methods it's time to unite
and finally
though i am alone voicing these concerns
publicly today i can tell you that i'm
not the only one who feels
to varying degrees
as i do within our ranks
i remain hopeful
that this call for more humanism for
more reason and for more hope will be
heard